left my own devices I would stop all
children been involved in religion until
the age of 16 I would ensure they had a
broad understanding of the world and
were able to make their own choices as
to what they actually believed instead
many are told what to think based on
their parents religious choice who let's
face it were probably told by their
parents what to think knowing I'll
probably face an uphill struggle in ever
getting that idea to pass I'll settle
for something else the banning of faith
schools if we truly want a society which
is tolerant integrated and understanding
of others we should not be separating
the next generation almost from day one
on their parents choice of religion it's
time to abolish the antiquated notion of
faith schools schools should be there to
teach not to preach
I don't like banning things particularly
but I also think that in this country
you know we have the Queen who's head of
the Church of England she's the Supreme
Governor of the Church of England we
have very many thousands and thousands
of church CoV Church Church of England
primaries it's like taking the eggs out
of a cake if you're going to take faith
schools out of the education system
do you object I'm not quite sure what
you're out of care calling it struggle
time a decent k1x minutes okay the eggs
after you've ate the cake right because
the it's fake are we going with the
faith schools are baked into the country
it's not and also parents don't use
newsflash faith schools simply because
they want to indoctrinate their children
in no I use faith schools like very good
CV primaries one because they are state
primaries two because they are very
highly rated and three because you know
their local schools and it's very odd to
try and say let's get rid of them can I
just say if these schools are so
horribly bad moschella why is it they
are actually faith scores about well let
me just give us some facts about they're
totally oversubscribed because parents
want their kids to go there and that
largely because the the educational
results are fantastic they very outflank
anything that happens in non faith
schools the children have an order they
have a way of doing things so that's why
the education is better there instilled
with a set of moral values this is very
important to all of that without the
fair well because that's what faith is
all about but but most importantly a lot
of these schools the resorts are
weighing above it and I think was the
type of a telegraph today their
Educational Supplement 2016 Catholic
schools outperformed non state school to
GCSE the Ofsted rated 81 percent of CV
schools as outstanding and and the most
important thing is that the people who
go to there is a faith school cap so
anyone who go to these schools only
fifty percent can be of that faith
you're the 50 percent getting nothing to
do with faith so if you object to faith
you wouldn't send your kids to one of
them's good but lots of people want to
get in there because of the intellection
come by our to succeed in my maths GCSE
I mean I don't I don't regard I don't
regard faith I don't need I don't need
to be doing prayers I don't need to be
celebrating Jesus in all different
religion unique names all happy clapping
stupid for a minute I don't relate and
that's fine you can have a structure
without having a religious structure I
don't feel that religion and GCSEs or
educational value need to be going
handling they do go hand in hand in they
work hand in hand quite surprised to
find out I mean if you have 37 percent
of primary schools in this country our
faith school 37% and I think 19% of
secondary schools and you say you have a
choice so that's in a lot of places you
don't have a choice because your local
school district and I personally think
there was a time when we could have done
what you suggested I think Tony Blair
when he first got elected because Tony
Blair because he was a religious zealot
himself actually expanded axillary gonna
again I can have an expansion of faith
schools at that particular time in
America it separated state schools you
had a mad
and faith a long long time ago that's a
much more religious commitment society
the wheel can I interrupt the blur
bashing just to throw in a statistic
which is we have got another very large
number of faith schools in the country
but you know as the cookie crumbles not
very many people say they're religious
at the end of it 18 to 24 year olds say
they 64% of them say they aren't and 28%
it's a smaller number of 65 to ninety
seven year olds why did they find all
this 97 year old that they were show
that they're not being indoctrinated
slightly I think respectfully your
suggestions a bit too simplistic because
I think if you want to have a lot of
Jewish kids educated together or a lot
of Muslim okay factor as long as they
are given a good appreciation of the
other phase where I side with you and I
won't name any faith but there had been
issue of some faith more than one that
have been found to actually be breaching
Ofsted regulations because of the way
they've taught religious religion
education religious studies whatever now
then I absolutely support you if you're
going to a Jewish school or you're going
to a Muslim school you must have a full
appreciation but simply saying faith
schools are wrong per se I kind of
suffocate if I'm a if I want my kidney
to go to a Catholic school if I was one
favor Academy I know but that's what I'm
saying if you choose to be a Catholic as
an adult
that's your choice that is to change
this how are you gonna know about
religion if you're not you know you
you're suggesting you're suggesting that
the parents don't talking about religion
either the whole parents how old job is
to create it's it's to create an ethos
for their kids to give them a moral and
any kid any captive kid who goes to a
Catholic faith school is not going to be
indoctrinated because they'll have been
taught about God since the day they were
born but I made sure I had to agree with
that I don't believe that parents should
instill their religious beliefs illusion
nothing's wrong with religion and I
actually go to church on okay it's not
what is my choice as an ad Michelle can
I allow a question I think the viewer
might be asking is do we do you have a
problem with let's say you know Nativity
plays in a church primary school or do
you have a problem with the fact that in
as Nicky Morgan who it when she was
education secretary once told me that
Ofsted and the education authorities are
too
frightened to go into Muslim some Muslim
academies in the middle in the around
Birmingham because you know they didn't
feel they were welcome they didn't feel
they could have a presence there what
are you worried about they've hit on a
really important point because I have a
massive problem with fear '[ __ ] Adam is
because therefore K don't have to teach
the national quick you know they can
just do whatever their warning so nice
explain what the danger is well you
can't just teach your kids whatever you
because that's like Anglican yes you
want to teach your kids you're talking
about a fare Academy whereby you don't
even need to follow the curriculum we're
talking about ever you most of the
people I know who went to catholic
secondary schools are more anti-catholic
video no I think does that retreat
they've taught by often by nuns who they
couldn't stand who were treated them
badly particularly the way it's not my
point it's not about what you come out
whether you're religious at my point is
that religious schools work
educationally their results are way
higher than schools just my results can
you so you know so you have a bunch of
children who are top of the table but
they're deeply unhappy well I'm not
saying that but you can't jump there's
more to an education than simply being
top of the table how honestly how did
they have separated the two in America
from the beginning state and managing
must separate because there were so many
systems yes and I personally think it's
a shame man go down there but I don't
think you have much chance of us going
there now I think we'll ever achieve
what I want but can I just introduced
this clip from my new favorite person I
know it's not turning Flair no is Andrew
Karsen and he's the chief exec of the
human issue care the reason is my
favorite person today is cuz he agrees
with me children by their parental
beliefs when what we should be doing is
being different backgrounds together to
make a better future there allows to
vary the curriculum they don't have to
teach objectively about different values
and beliefs but what we should be doing
and for missing them access to the broad
range of the world's traditions so they
can make their own minds up and they
also divide people socially
in our society because the way their
missions processes work means that only
really pushing middle-class parents
often get access to those schools about
how many smiles die like how would a
belief a school C's be they're not many
bad the sound of it they're not device C
that's what their school by the way yeah
I did yeah I love this but I'm gonna
stop happy but what it did teach me some
values the did teach me stuff that to
this day I followed the rules of and I
think that's pretty important I'm gonna
rate that debate outstanding next after
the break I'll be delivering a serving
of reality to the panel